un suelo seco y agrietado rodea la isla
de long sin ton la roca coronada por una
pagoda suele estar rodeada de agua en
agosto en medio del mayor lago de agua
dulce de china
normalmente el agua llega hasta allí el
nivel más alto que se alcanza es aquí
el verano pasado tuvimos agua hasta aquí
y en toda la línea este es el aspecto
que tenía hace dos años cuando la región
se vio afectada por las inundaciones el
nivel de agua del lago poyang fluctúa ya
que las aguas del río yangtsé fluyen
hacia él durante el verano normalmente
húmedo antes de retroceder drásticamente
en otoño e invierno este año el lago ya
se ha reducido a una quinta parte de su
tamaño china está experimentando el
verano más caluroso de su historia como
una ola de calor que dura ya más de 70
días y está batiendo récords con
temperaturas que alcanzan los 40 grados
celsius en chongqing algunos residentes
están durmiendo en centros comerciales y
estaciones de metro con aire
acondicionado para mantenerse frescos
las grandes ciudades han tenido que
atenuar las luces debido a la escasez de
energía hidroeléctrica el clima extremo
amenaza la cosecha de este año a uno de
los mayores exportadores agrícolas del
mundo
mira estos pimientos están secos y
morirán pronto
he perdido la mitad de la cosecha de
hortalizas en comparación con los
tiempos normales la provincia sureña de
juve y las autoridades han comenzado a
dispersar productos químicos por el
cielo para inducir la lluvia el proyecto
de siembra de nubes continuará durante
los próximos tres meses en un esfuerzo
desesperado por proteger los cultivos